俺の名前は、はじめしゃちょー
youtuberをやっている。
youtubeの世界は目立ってなんぼ
だからyoutuberは髪の毛や見た目を
気にする奴が少なくない。
俺も久しぶりに髪の毛を染めてみた。
銀色にな。
銀色の髪色をしているyoutuberはほぼ見たことがないし、
実際俺も、銀色にしてから、目立っているだろう。
だが、銀髪の寿命は短い。
髪の毛に色を入れた人なら分かると思うが
色は落ちる。
そして銀色は
特に
落ちやすい(小声)
クッソォォォォォ
もうかなり銀が抜けてきたなぁ…
最初はめっちゃくちゃ銀色だったのになぁ…
くっそ…一週間でこんなに抜けんのかよぉ
ハァ－
気に入ってたのになぁ…
「とっとと落としちまえよぉぉぉ!」
だれだぁ!!
♪～　ロッキーなミュージック
ハァッ!
も…
もうひとりの…
僕!?
（これは、「ヤベ…銀髪の俺マジカッケェー）
（ちょっと色落ちちゃったけどまだ銀色でいたいなぁ、、、」）
（と、思うはじめの心と）
（「イヤイヤイヤ、｣）
(「夏っしょ夏ぅ。夏といえば金髪。」)
（「派手髪でパリピで、暴れたいぜ!ウェーイ!」）
（と思っているはじめの心が対立し、）
（2つの心が具現化され、今まさにはじめの心の中で）
（戦っている状態なのである。）
金「そんなに長くもたない髪色ぉなんて非効率だよぉ!!」
金「おぉい、はじめ」
金「さっさと金髪にしちまえよぉ!!」
金「アッハッ八ァァー」
銀「うるさいっ!!」
銀「き…去年は金髪にしたんだよ!」
銀「それにお前、Twitterの評判もよかったぞぉ」
銀「銀髪の…画像なんて6000リツイートだぁ! 　どうだ!」
金「そんなに長くもたない髪色なんて非効率だよぉ!」
金「おい、はじめ」
金「とっとと金髪にしちまおうぜぇぇ!!」
金「ヘェァ!!」
銀「（小声）それでも…」
銀「それでも俺は!」
銀「今年の夏は…」
銀「銀髪でいきたい!!」
金「だが所詮は一週間ももたないんだなぁ～（煽り）」
金「なぁ～、金髪だったら色落ちもしないぞぉぉ～?」
銀「俺は銀をあきらめない!」
銀「この、ムラサキシャンプー」
銀「そして、この紫色とちょっと紫色っぽいマニックパニックを使えば!」
銀「俺の銀色のシーズンはぁ!」
銀「まだ、続くはずだぁ!!」
金「っだめだよそんな髪色じゃぁｗｗｗｗ」
金「夏といえば」
金「金!」
金「さっさとそんな色落としちまえよぉ!」
金「ハッ八ッ」
金「あ!」
金「そういえば」
金「お前の後輩見てみろよぉ!」
金「コリャァ(謎)」
金｢ハッハッハッハッハァｗｗ｣
金｢金髪に染めちまってるぜぇ!ｗｗ｣
銀｢ハッ…｣
銀｢つる兄!!｣
銀｢お前なんて姿に…｣
銀｢そのままだと金髪になっちまう!!｣
つる兄｢きんぱつ｣
銀｢これ以上ブリーチをしたら…｣
銀｢ハゲちまう｣
金｢そんなの関係ねぇよぉ!｣
金｢お前帰れ!　帰れ!｣
冷蔵庫｢バタン｣
金｢今の若いうちに楽しんどこうぜぇ｣
金｢俺たちのゴールデンエイジをなぁ!!｣
銀｢俺らはお前なんかに負けない!　いくぞ!｣
銀｢ムラサキシャンプー!｣
銀｢そして!｣
銀｢マジックパニック! ウルトラヴァイオレットヴァージンスノー｣
金｢かかってこいよぉ!｣
金｢敵を殲滅しろ!｣
金｢ホワイトブリーチ｣
銀｢うわぁあぁぁぁ～!｣
金｢うわぁあぁぁぁ～!｣
金銀｢うわぁあぁぁぁ～!｣
金｢うわぁぁぁぁぁっ｣
金｢あ?｣
照明｢コンッ｣
金｢アハッ 金じゃねぇかｗｗ｣
♪～ED　最後まで視聴ありがとうございました！
テテテテン
金｢かかってこいよぉ!｣
金｢敵を殲滅しろ!｣
金｢ホワイトブリーチィ!｣
金｢マジでダさい(苦笑)｣